I leave in are you on your way back home
either way we wanna be there doesn't
matter how much baggage you claim give
us time and made Terminal and gate we
wanna send you off in style we wanna
welcome you back home tell us all about
it we scared or was it fine now
do you need a ride do you need a mine do
you need a ride do you need a ride do
you need with Karen and Chris welcome -
do you need a ride this is Chris
Fairbanks this is Karen kill Gareth that
position No okay right Karen is driving
my Honda carb we are in the car that's
what you heard right
yeah that's a video you can tell by the
lowered sound quality guys this is we're
back to our roots mm-hmm a root says
some might say some people say Creek or
Creek I mean I want to say whatever
sounds the most old-fashioned yeah and
kind of wild Westy my favorites we're
back to our roots thank you thank you
that guy pulled all the way over and he
didn't mean to and sometimes I find
that's passive-aggressive think he's
being condescending yeah I thought but
then it also could just be maybe he just
paid his car off and he's just like
please God can I just have a nice thing
for five minutes well people that live
up here there's a reason I don't know
where we are do you know where we are
we're in the Burbank Hills oh it's
beautiful look at that reindeer they're
ready they are ready for the holidays
it's pretty nice up here it is very nice
up here and whenever someone lives in a
nice place I'd consider it some version
of white flight like they're scared of
people and of course they pull over when
they're driving because they think the
world is going to attack them yes they
did there watch a lot of Fox News
probably and they're told the world is
going to attack them because that is
what's financially beneficial for Fox
News yeah but I find also those same
people that are like that also are the
same people who get purebred dogs bring
them to the dog park and then Elite will
not leave the dog alone the
entire time it's at the dog park
oh yeah when when people get frustrated
that their dog is playing with other
dogs which is the why dog parks exist
and the only thing a dog wants to do
they don't want to play catch with you
they don't give two about you and
your girlfriend they just want to go run
around and of course my garbage dog
Frank who can't not bark at every dog he
sees will run up to try to get the dog
to chase him and bark at the dogs and
then they're like um stop scout and then
like start pulling the dog toward them
as if Frank's going to attack them and
instead instead of understanding that
that's how dogs interact and play with
each other and it's one of the most
irritating things there is I don't I
don't like people at dog parks I do like
dogs at dog parks I'm not a dog owner
but I the times I've been to a dog park
with a friend's dog just watching them
team up in two clicks mm-hmm
very high okay they do that get into
groups and they're like let's hang out
you have a similar build to be as me
yeah so we're gonna have some animosity
at first but then we're gonna team up
and then they're they of course team up
on a little dog and knock him over and
he rolls around and knocks over the
water bowl it's so fun yeah to watch dog
communities form on some primitive level
it's like a society building I love it
I do too and I love watching my dog
that's an ugly mustard-colored yeah
that's a horrible house we're talking
about 1770 go ahead and everything they
won't see it because its yolk colored
what if there's like an old man sitting
in his gorgeous Bose speaker drum inside
that house listening to our podcast me
here's his address it's just like what
the I finally made it hey they're
insulting my beautiful mustard home I'm
insulted yet so excited to be mentioned
on diner I'm and I know our head from
way back if there is a bus we used to do
acid he's gonna city to city
I'm done with that character yeah it's
hard these are it's hard on the old
vocal cords
I am I die now means something other
than do you need a ride abbreviated an
acronym oh yeah
anytime a rebated word you say it and
it's a word yeah it's called an acronym
people often again take call MIT for
instance an acronym no those are
initials unless you call it MIT oh I see
do you speak it out as well so dine R is
in reference to something what if on
Instagram every time I tagged a photo or
something diner or Twitter whatever your
social medias but there's a hundreds of
them and I click on it and it's like
Indian folks so in India I think it
means something like a celebration maybe
or what if it means one of its at me
what if we let it wait maybe I should do
that research I mean we could what if
we're proclaiming something religious or
political I feel like and this is a
total guess isn't diner or Dean are
diner money in India it could be like
the dollar over there but it's spelled
with an i knotted y know this Dyn AR is
a trending always there's always
hundreds of people talking about diner
and then I'll click on it and it's
people and in dressed up and nice robes
and burkas and whatever it shawls
pashmina z' some wrong bedazzled capes
bindis something for head
yes bolero ties I'm saying wear it but
it is Dino Dino is something and someday
we'll find out what it is yeah yeah
and do a special special episode on when
looked it up right now and they're gonna
so don't let us know someone corrected
me the other day that the the cook from
you can't do that on television his is
not barf it's barf
I don't know maybe it was during another
podcast I don't know
I wonder oh there's someone that liked
it enough to correct you during a
different talk they broke up they opened
their laptop they cracked their knuckles
and they fired off a tweet directly to
me that's kind of but don't you think he
was named Barth because it sounds like
barf and he was a cook and a children's
whatever sketch show or whatever it was
also I know the guys name isn't barf
well I think I said I don't know who
cares you can't do that on podcast you
can't be wrong about barf on podcasts
these houses are beautiful I know aren't
they nice look at that one what do these
people do for a living
something respectable they all own a
piece of the Zankou chicken Empire
almost all of them I actually looked at
houses in this area parents funny I
looked at houses in this area long ago
when I bought my house and there are
this is a very Armenian neighborhood
which is what that joke is about if
you're from a different part of the
country and didn't get it Oh Sam ku is
local chicken yes restaurant that
everyone loves and this is a vis the
highest percentage of population of
Armenians outside of Armenia is in
Glendale really which is where we are
we're the Glendale Burbank Hills Wow and
this there's tons of Armenians around
here and there
magenta houses that I looked at they
loved tile marble tile and gold fixtures
oh yeah that was almost all the houses
around here the outside it looks like a
normal ranch-style house but the inside
it looks like a gorgeous palace but only
like say 1,100 square feet I think yeah
I used to like tile and gold fixtures or
brass you know I'm not rich I grew up
with a lot of brass from a store down
the street called oak and brass we're
hoping there was made of oak and or bur
house so that's so 80 but yeah yeah it
was so 80s everything there it's it's
just walking into the 80s but look in
brass I I it would be a miracle of that
places so I think it is it's part of a
place called Furniture Row it just had
to get absorbed by some sort of mattress
outfit yes first or by Moda italia mm or
whatever that place is it'd be fun to
wear a mattress outfit and then just
kind of purposefully fall down oh sorry
everyone that's that's what they call
curve ball in the biz yeah no one saw
that mattress outfit joke coming it was
a shocking and no one said goodbye no
one let it in the front door and they
everybody locked down for the evening
are you saying that I shouldn't have
that be my Halloween costume mattress
outfit yeah just I'm a bed no I'm
kidding
but you will get tired with in the first
half hours you're really mad it would be
funny to dress up like a pretty
convincing bed a guy in his bed yeah I
bet I bet that's been done I'm gonna do
I mean I did it before I did a guy
sitting on a toilet so I turned my body
waste down into a toilet I had paper
mache my real toilet put it around my
waist made little fake foam rubber legs
the carving nice and a carving knife and
a mattress so it really looked like I
sitting on a toilet and it looked like
the fake legs where my legs I'm sitting
it was so fun people loved it I went to
costume contests once 200 bucks here 150
here yes I just swept the town yes I
didn't even have fun that night I saw it
as a way to make money it was you were a
businessman and I'm not anymore I
I had in my early 20s you could do this
again I think I want to yeah I think you
should you're an artist started on it
you're comedian and an artist you're the
one of the few people who can actually
do a funny halloween costume correctly
you know there's a lot of people who are
like I know I'll do a funny Halloween
costume I'm gonna be a racist I'm gonna
be in the KKK like that really like
no they say isn't funny you men be why
would you put your time into that right
I don't just think about how many people
this year are gonna be dressed as Trump
it makes me want to stay home well
that's why I stay home so many people
are gonna be Trump this year yeah just
what their shitty wig think of it if
there's a guy that and he's in a
store-bought Trump costume I'm gonna
treat him like the actual Donald Trump
and spit right on him
Yeah right into his bird's nest I'm
gonna grab his sorry I had to say
it it's topical where apparently we're
all allowed to say it now you can say
as much as you want they do it on
the news the flake it's not a problem
the funny thing is I listen to that and
I was of course horrified but when he
said the way his delivery and it was
like being in a boys locker room hearing
that it's all I left thinking after
hearing that conversation was so much I
didn't like Billy Bush because he
already was defending Ryan lochley and
defending rape and stuff right wasn't
yeah he's a piece of already yeah
he's here buddy no one knew so with the
trump card I'm like yeah oh wow he said
the wrong thing but when he said oh I
just go up and I grabbed him by the
he was trying to he was being fun
he was trying to shock Billy Bush and
make him laugh and it worked and then
yeah it worked so I wasn't I left that
thinking at Trump ease same old Trump
but Billy Bush he can go eat it yeah he
deleted as a Twitter account
did he really I'm sure people were
really attacking what an admittance of
guilt oh yes every every comment it's
about him because the Trump thing isn't
really news well also you know that's I
feel like that's like kind of it boils
down to a thing like that whereas
but he knows kind of what top Trump is
on the surface it's that thing of and I
think it's an impossible request but
it's that thing that like women talk
about all the time we're just like the
Billy bushes are worse than the Trump's
cuz Trump you can see coming it's the
Billy Bush that you would trust that you
would tell stuff to that you would you
would treat like a friend and that you
would expect to be treated that way and
they're the ones that like but then when
it's boys time like all bets are off and
you can just like demean whoever
whenever for your own joy that's the
that's why I think what women really
fear are the fake fake friends that are
actually just total pigs yeah
it's a shame there's some guy UCB actor
guy that the you know I'd go a part of
the show of sometimes as a judge and
he's one of the performers and he seems
nice and but he has this alter ego that
online he says horrible anti-women
things as a as a rape but what do you
call it when someone does that thing
pathologist rape apologist yeah and it's
not a character I don't think I think no
there's a lot of guys that are like that
horrifying cuz you wouldn't know
from looking at the dude or talking to
him it seems nice but once that was out
there you know it's just so horrible
that how often is that person just
walking around and you think they're
just a normal nice guy or maybe if at
worst socially awkward or whatever but
inside they're seething haribol there
are terrible things because their mom
burned them in a bathtub when they're a
kid yes or or for no reason just because
there is their social path yeah exactly
or that yeah they had either a bad mom
or they had a way to nice mom or
whatever there's lots of reasons that
people are damaged every relationship I
have that doesn't go well I blame on
being circumcised too late he did a
sloppy job I don't know why I signed his
initials I used to blame it a lot on
that I was nurse the nursing and ended
too quickly for me but then my mother
said when I told her that I'd read the
somewhere and my mother said it's always
the mother's fault oh that's funny and I
was like oh yeah I guess that's true
yeah like it's never like what if it's
because your dad was withholding or
whatever or your dear dad was basically
actually pulling you away from her
breath now it's my turn now he would
yell at a child we hate this no you know
what now I'm on that roof apologist side
because it all makes sense see if you
just explain that at the be one milky
character but I have to say remember you
know five years ago at the beginning of
the like rape jokes are fine whatever
Second Amendment or whatever the
argument that everyone was at Oh Oh kind
of spurred people are talking about it
because of some Daniel Tosh yeah yeah it
was a joke and man it's a bad example of
someone it he just there's no way that
joke could be funny the setting it up
that way of saying everything's funny no
matter what the end of that joke has to
be so funny that it's impossible your
judt himself by even setting something
up that way because it's like well first
of all I don't know how funny you are to
begin with and now you're basically
setting up this bar that you have to
jump over that you're not going to be
able to I've heard the real Joe and it
is it the people talking about it
afterwards it was worse it the way he
delivered it I remember yeah it wasn't
the funniest joke in the world but it
also wasn't he wasn't simply saying rape
is funny or it was I can't remember I
it's so hard to talk about people's
material but there's so many better
examples I think of offensive
rip the people I just meant I do think
audiences act appropriately though when
just when that word comes up yeah
they're kind of trained to not laugh
yeah well that's you know part part of
my point is that that when that
discussion started it seems so
impossible because there was many many
more rape joke apologists and people who
are like look it's not a problem or
whatever and you know over time I think
people have slowly become to wake up to
the fact that just because like it can't
or doesn't or hasn't happened to you
that doesn't mean you get to dictate how
people receive that right topic and like
it's simply that it's not about there's
no answer to whether or not it's funny
because it's purely you know you have to
be a great comic to be funny about a
thing that's that sensitive there are
some who can do it many who cannot many
who think the dumbest joke I have that
is making light of pedophile like where
I'm like I'm not trying to factor kid
he's a redhead that statement hahaha but
it is what if someone you don't even
think about what if there's a redheaded
person that was molested yeah and
they're sitting there and I really
touched on something I guess I'm willing
to take that risk well I mean exactly
there's grease on that wrist there's
someone in the audience always that has
gone through something and it doesn't
matter if you're being quote-unquote
risky or not that has that has a
sensitive I've learned that oh right no
jokes
I got quit doing that one laughs I've
never heard you do that go it's oh it's
about me I like kids and when I see kids
I'm at the age where I should have kids
maybe or this paternal instinct has
kicked in and I talked to kids that
aren't my kids all the time like I don't
if I'm in a mall or whatever and people
of course think that's weird if you're
like hey how are you buddy usually the
parents are right there but just talking
about talking about makes people nervous
so that's why I throw that joke in there
and it really relieves the tension but
it also makes people think I'm weird
well it's but that's funny because
that's true like men your age single men
kind of can't talk to children mm-hmm
especially with that mustache you a
bright now yeah it makes it even worse
with your windowless van yeah I just
don't think it's a good I think the hot
tubs too much I mean in the back of the
van yes thank you make me I'm bad Milo
don't tell you know I do I do I do like
kids I went to the house my friend don't
say it like that I love kids if I don't
sing Kyle growly look I know he's the
cutest get him
there's just a little kid jumping in
yelling yeah I guess I need to have some
air hang out with my nieces and nephew
that'll fulfill the desire I shouldn't
be having kids shouldn't be accurate
just kids around me around my lap oh it
was that comic that said sitting on a
throne of boys but Matt he was so angry
Bretton no from back in the day Matt
wine holder
oh yeah he's all funny he was great he
is Graham he's he's still alive and rest
oh sure
doing great comedy is he doing stand-up
yeah I'm sure I mean I have I see him
like once a year oh okay
he's the best look at her outfit is that
Kim Kardashian wow it sure looks like
someone that follows her beauty tips yes
she had a lot of contouring going on she
was a gorgeous woman and there was
cutouts in her little black dress that's
how I first noticed her was it looked
like a chunk of her upper thigh dress
was missing
Wow you didn't notice I didn't notice
that no I looked straight at her face
out of respect right in the eyes and I
not ma'am I say to myself
um we're very close to the moonlight
roller rink right now have you ever been
there no you've never gone rollerskating
a movie it's an old-fashioned like
straight out of the 80s roller skate I I
do like rollerskating I do enjoy it I'm
decent at it how about bowling going
counterclockwise oddly similar leg thing
that I do when I'm bowling I take my
right one slide it behind the left just
was skating I do it repeatedly that's
right
not just as a celebratory move very much
the same form yeah yeah I'm good at both
I'm really pretty good at roller skating
I'm speaking of paedophiles though there
was a ice rink in Culver City that sadly
just closed but it was real cool because
it's just it's realized it's indoor of
course it's called it's not all year
round but I I've been there a couple
times because it was near my place in
marvista and it's mostly kids but there
was a guy there that was in all black
with like a turtleneck and he was just
creepy in general yeah and he had
bedazzled skates like he covered his
skates with gems and he had these rings
like the Emperor's New Clothes rings and
he was going up to kids and shining its
rings and they'd be like okay weirdo and
they kind of look at the Rings and then
skate away then he was he knew that
children loved he was skating around
doing little spins and just being real
creepy and then at one point he was on
the side I was on a date he was on the
side of the rink just looking through
the glass into the like snack area yeah
there's just kids in there eating and
he's just staring at them
I was I just went up to him and I said
you're acting peculiar that's all I said
but he got very defensive and he and
then he just starts focusing on but I
think he was getting away from himself
yeah and and basically licking
his lips it was real gross and scary did
you did he leave and I had to tell this
story because I wanted to contrast my
jokey pedophile she had been good idea
that you're also do no good in the
community yeah he knew what I meant when
I said that yeah what else was being
real weird he was shown as rings - whoo
sparkly it's funny cuz most of the kids
are like yeah I've seen a fake emerald
before you weirdo yeah it's not that's
not the thing kids are into jewelry I
don't know if this used to work with you
back in the nine days but kids don't
care about your jewels or back when you
were Vlad the Impaler decent skater at
one point he had a career on ice do you
think did he shoot the duck we probably
had kids on ice and it's uh I don't know
what is shoots the shoot the duck that's
when you squat down and put one leg up
straight in front of you and then the
other one stays in oh yes he did she's
in the bedroom I described something
that did sound like a sexual body
position say that go in there with the a
lot of people would've did what I just
did yes that's my point a lot of people
what else could've oh look at this man
sleeping on a bus bench oh and he's a
regular guy he's got like dre headphones
you know what he looks like to me it's
like they they're tourists and they've
spent the day trying to get around
Burbank in Los Angeles and they're like
out here stuck at that bus stop and he's
had it yeah I bet you're right that I
feel so bad for tourists that come to LA
oh it is there's this Japanese couple
that we're walking around with a map
side down and they were like trying to
they were walking along by the studio
paramount and I I was like they just
came up and they're like handed me the
map and they're like Highland oh let's
see and then I had trouble with the map
which was in all English it's like who
the is Highland on here
and I and I had to direct that day I was
like you have to walk like ten miles
that way and not and I tried to tell
them about uber and they didn't know
what I stay in though and their phones
ruined Japanese and I'm just like
I'm sorry and they just were I felt so
bad because they wanted to go up to
Hollywood and Highland probably they
wanted to like see the Hollywood sure
and they why not
a translation book how can you they were
kid they were very young they they were
basically me if I went to Europe when I
was or somewhere where they actually
taught speaking you know I was young but
I can see like well we'll just go there
and walk around it'll work out not
working not working at it well but it
rarely works out for tourists in
Hollywood because it once you get away
from Hollywood and Highland and vine and
LaBrea which is basically what three
block four block distance mmm
it's town it's awful you either
make it into the town or you're by
that point you're already in the sex
industry yet all they do sex
you've been sold in and you're just
doing it for a living it's tiring the
decor is not that nice it's mostly brass
yeah I can't but we've only been
podcasting for 25 minutes is that
surprising it is surprising to me yeah
but it's the clock off on this beast no
well maybe just because we'd already
started
oh yes yes we did it seems like one
previous thing well previously on diner
I'd like to record all of our previous
Leon's if we ever have to do that oh
that would be really fun previously on
diner
I'll do it like that has there been
there probably has been but Martha Kelly
did a Funny or Die thing it was like
with BJ Porter and and Scott it what's
called what's it called would say parody
of a soap opera
Lake Charles lake did you ever see that
no I was a guy it was like an overly
dramatic Joe Wagner was in it and he was
great
Martha was great and I was in it take
was in a Patrick Keene was in it it was
really fun and it was a parody of soap
operas and there was a lot of recaps and
previously on and I want to do that
again I think someone should do that
again well now I'm just giving the idea
away it's not well someone already did
it you can't give it away who's - who
did it you guys did it oh yeah you're
right you're right I forgot about the
version that I just brought up you're
not talking about a dream you hope comes
true it happened
it is good yet it's good that it is
online permanently I someone that I hate
was did Q&A at the graduation at some
comedy class today yeah and they asked
if I worry about firing off my jokes on
Twitter which I thought was a good idea
brand new comedian people and I said I
don't worry about it at all because if
anything you're taking your idea and
your time stamping it perfectly and yeah
as evidence in case you see someone I
think it keeps a lot of people from
doing that it's yes or does it I don't
know maybe I'm being naive well I mean
at the temp the time stamp thing really
is a is the main reason that I don't not
do it because that's what I used to
think the same thing but it's like a
if you want to be a comedy writer and if
you're doing stand-up you are a comedy
writer then you should get used to
churning out massive levels of material
that's part of it right and when you can
timestamp it then any all of that is
just like oh I thought of that first
then you actually have proof if you
thought of it first or not yeah but for
the most part you should just
there should be no joke that you think
is so precious and dear that you can't
make it public that way right yeah I
wish that it had been around when I had
that Demetri Martin problem where it had
similar to hers verbatim and I was like
hey take my word for it rather than
being accusing someone I'm like I have a
job just like that I wish that I had had
Twitter or something when it was on or
on YouTube I didn't I didn't have that
kind of proof and you know it's like I
think it's handy so that's what I should
have said to that class well I mean you
know they shouldn't be doing stand-up
anyway so it's fine don't worry no one
new should get it it's so so much of me
wanted to say that because every my
stance on it they were asking all these
hopeful questions and I think I was just
oh my god it takes no now it takes at
least 15 years and yeah you're gonna
keep asking for work but you might not
get it success comes and goes right now
and I mean a real lull is this helping
you guys you're just crying wanted to
hear like how do you get work and I'm
like still a mystery to me and I make a
living doing I don't respond okay next
question well and also I'm glad you did
that because really the answer is no one
can walk you through this you don't get
the easy way is especially in stand-up
comedy if you really want to do it you
have to go and eat for a long time
and get better that's all I kept saying
is I just keep doing it and I don't know
I don't know why I'm doing it
things happen peripherally Joe jobs you
know writing jobs of commercial work
hosting jobs things but I just keep
doing stand-up it's fun I like it yep I
don't know why you shouldn't ask why you
should just want it you should know why
you want to do
it's really asking someone why they do
it oh god it was you were there to be
behind me like Flavor Flav and just yell
yell at children who are
just trying something
stop trying this you already failed
there's no reason to start doing
stand-up that isn't the wrong one um no
matter what it is you're always wrong
you're always and there's there to be
good at stand-up there has to be
something deeply wrong with you yep to
be a funny person you need to be in
serious pain yep and very flawed
all the time you had to be yanked away
from a breast you had to be burned in a
tub you had to just have a deep-seated
personality disorder where you're a
narcissist yep self-serving and also
don't have a lot of shame or feelings or
you or you just got funny parents and
they were like hey you're funny do you
want to do comedy that's sometimes
that's necessary some level of that
happen so if your parents or boring or
should probably become an
accountant or a therapist probably
everything good yeah do you have a lot
there are I wonder who I can't think of
anyone right now but I know they exist
funny legitimately funny people to wear
when you meet their parents you're like
oh my god how April Richardson April
it's but now that I there but no her mom
wasn't I could tell that she has a good
sense of him yeah yeah just not not a
good you know sense of it's not like
comedy style or whatever what am I
saying
she loves Steve ha she loves Department
like if you love a comedian look there's
the debate oh wow I should be watching
it I'm supposed to watch it oh it's
right now it's happening but I can catch
up later I'm I feel a little fatigued I
feel like I know what's gonna happen I
watched the first one in it I was in
such a deep cringe the entire time that
I hurt my neck yeah because it's I he
shouldn't be there really hurt your neck
yes we were watching it at work so we
were I was facing I had to look to the
left to watch it for an hour
and it was him going wrong wrong and all
day everything about his sweating
doesn't yeah he doesn't know the rules
he doesn't have real answers he he's a
fraud and yet he is so psychotically
narcissistic that he thinks he's getting
away with it and yet he still had a
couple of throw applause breaks like
yeah but some mention oh maybe it was
you and I talking about it yeah because
the the people that are that support him
are they would applaud him murdering a
baby with his hands they're there
they're not okay yeah there's a section
at the debate in the audience for
overalls only well and also you were
they were told repeatedly you can't
applaud and they did it of course anyway
because these days in our society
everyone thinks they're the exception of
the rule right and so it doesn't matter
if the rule says you can't do it I can
because it's me is everything in our
society and I really I'm coming down on
society isn't it so of course pence
would not have had anything to do with
the debate tonight the vice presidential
one but did he ever read did you it's
not official yet but he's dropped out
most likely there's there's rumors that
he is being asked asked to be he is
asking to be taken off the ticket oh you
can't take yourself up I mean I don't
know I wonder I I don't I think it's
like if you get nominated you're that's
an official thing he just keeps going to
places with wite-out and no no not me no
no no no don't pick me
no it's eddy pence Los Angeles comedian
oh here's flappers I headlined this
place Jeff Garlin's in there
look at that jab tonight is he doing
some loose material he's gonna loosen
loose meet it up he's gonna loosey goose
it up Jimmy Pardo Jimmy Pardo here's a
plug for flappers Jimmy Pardo October
10th
Pauly Shore that will be a show worth
going to Jimmy Pardo yeah Jimmy Pardo is
he's one of my I mean he's not that old
enough to be but he is one of my comedy
dad's a little bit yes it took me a hero
on the road no no father Lee oh I see I
advise I don't I don't
yeah it's weird to say he did always
it's very great showed it's watched
together it would be fun we used to he'd
take me to lunch when we are on the road
I mean you'd go to a restaurant he's
like hi how are you my dad fuse in town
this is my nephew to the waiter and then
they're like oh yeah he just graduated
from Naval Academy Tom Chris tell him
about the Navy come on like play along
otherwise he'd actually get mad and it's
so it's that thing that he does and like
Todd glassware they assign you a comedy
sketch that you do not want to do but
you have to do it yeah there's an
obligation to do it with only I would
literally walk away if that was so don't
want to trick normal people who don't
understand anything that's happening I
didn't want to either very fun version
at the Olive Garden where I had to talk
about him being my uncle for quite a
while and that you're in the Army the
Navy or the Air Force or the marine or
the Marines I couldn't remember which
branch we don't ask for experience we
give it Wow remember that commercial no
I was harming Navy Air Force Marines we
don't ask for experience we give it and
we don't something else we live it Wow
remember it sounds more like it's a
jingle for Pontiac
Taurus now there's an American car
that's exactly what you've been looking
for
and a Ford
lady you remember the English rock
version the mountains right now are
being kissed by an angle of the Sun that
can only be described as beautiful this
is Magic Hour they call it in the movies
where the Sun Goes Down but it's still
up but the all the light gets diffused
it's very pinkish it's called Twilight
hour you're wrong
Magic Hour yep look at the Sun as a
cascades over the idea that I went to
twice this week Hawaii I went to
buy curtains they were labeled under the
ones they had on display perfect size
for my windows the ones I reached down a
grab were made for a castle they went
all the way to the yeah they were big
long tapestry flags like like Hitler
used to have it as speeches you couldn't
cut him in half and have four curtains
yeah but they still had that swastika
that's good you know we want this we
went to Staples before this pocket I
started to buy it what do you call it
card and the girl I don't know if you
notice that girl that works there she
had red hair and a ponytail and lipstick
on and I was already at Staples earlier
today buying printer ink and so when I
walked in she had it was the funniest
thing she had that look of shock on her
face oh that's funny um how are you here
twice in a day yeah I have to come here
once a day and I don't understand it
yeah
it was like she wanted to say what your
back but she didn't say that's funny
yeah that IKEA there's a greeter and he
is from Sweden he's like an old Swedish
guy oh and uh do they have that at all
of them are just that one I don't know
he just happens to be so they're like we
got to get it done we gotta get this guy
to at least hand out shopping carts for
some and he remembers me having left a
couple days earlier and I came back to
return the curtains and he's like
returning those curtains huh and I'm
like whoa
because that hundreds of people he had
small talk with I'm just saying that guy
had a great memory
he deserves a free meatball sold worthy
78 oh dude yeah so he's doing good
mm-hmm he's doing well yeah where it's
like when if someone's above 65 and they
have a better memory than me I want to
give them like a Nobel Peace Prize if
there's work if I need an old lady in
the store you know every once in a while
I don't know if this happens here it
happens to me a lot
old ladies will talk to me like if we're
both in their fruit section or whatever
sure I'll be like I thought these
peaches went out of week ago whatever
I'm always having
yeah those kind of conversations and
anytime it's a lady who looks like she
could be 78 or 88 I when I walk away I
start crying god bless him for still
being so sharp that they are out
shopping for themselves yet probably
drove themselves they're getting it done
and then aren't riddled with Alzheimer's
I love it I and I also cry at that and I
think that it's obviously because we
both them
that's in common no I think it's because
I'm bipolar oh it's because of your
emotional problem okay well then I don't
know why I do it
maybe I just had something in my eye
every time I talk to the elderly oh you
should go to an allergist yeah sure
you're allergic to old people
I'm Santa Ana winds now we're driving
into the Sun but it's such a pleasant
experience because it's the whole sky is
gold it is entirely gold it is gold like
the end of the outsiders and I don't
know if that means is there a fire or is
it just there's a haze over the
mountains the Sun is just I think we've
got a marine layer and I think that's
that's making everything look real
Pleasant what we have here is a cold
front coming in over the initial Arctic
flow causing what will be tomorrow hey
folks sunshine do you think I could have
been a meteorologist yes thank you
voice alone you could uh that's probably
just the voice I am I like to look and
see if we are ever again what the
percentage chance of rain is it's been
0% for literally one year I'm going
crazy
I need moisture from San Francisco where
there's fog and rain often and this
place is like an old caked up leftover
bar of soap in an abandoned house we
live in a in a urinal cake with crime
it's terrible there's got to be people
that hear us listening you know our fans
and Seattle and Portland that just are
like you yes all the people are
going through the hurricane there's
standing right now with headphones
drenched like looking like the girl from
the ring just wet well jealous if you're
please know that I am jealous of you
yeah if you're a damp right now in any
way for any reason and I don't want to
hear why I'm jealous it is a classic
case of the grass being greener on the
other side except here it's all dead so
it's not that case there's no because
there's no green there is no grass here
there's it's all flown away and burned
up yeah god damn it god damn we're in a
drought and we were angry about it we
just want one rinse off that's all I
need he could rain for 15 minutes
to get some of this oil off the streets
and these these or the oil off all these
goddamn birds with oil they're filthy
Birds
they have combination skin they need an
acne mask of some kind but first rinses
shirt I bought like two different night
masks Oh more fun the other night
because someone with Tourette's
basically said oh man you got some
wrinkles this year oh I'm like what like
I guess I have some laughs why are crows
you know it's inevitable I'm right all
right no look my age whatever but also
that's it's a natural thing for your
face to bend at certain areas yeah yeah
I know I just but I bought some I bought
it lonna lotions because they're like
normally $50 and they're $5 and some
under a pair of underwear at Ross that's
right
probably because there's a chemical in
them that burns off didn't it just burn
does it burn there is a like red patches
on my face I don't think it's good for
you
is it a retinol is the disease of the
ingredient retinol in it
Oh should I not be using that well it's
just various that's the strongest one
you can have that's like that's like
middle-aged lady face max oh no I didn't
see that yeah though that's shit's
really expensive like a rock brand
retinol therapy yes that's but it
actually works of all the news that they
say work retinol okay because you're
burning off your skin because yes you
have to you just take it off just micro
layer by micro layer what about a little
bit and guys it's really funny that I'm
a man who's
is ready to have this conversation yeah
been in fistfights in my life but I am
the lotion that I have that has alpha
hydroxy acid yes does that work that's
very good yes it's just Neutrogena
you know it's a man's lotion that's
slightly tinted but I didn't do that
that's not a man's lips I shaved the
other day and put it on it was hurl
I was Macaulay Culkin from that sixteen
and Daniel Ceron takes it in the nuts
later turned to movie called home alone
right it it really burned my face like
like sea breeze Oh remember sea breeze
Oh God oh my god it's and that is
so bad for your skin like sea breeze and
and like st. Ives apricot scrub yeah
like that's the worst thing you could do
only attack me yes oh wow all those
things and that's why all we were doing
my beautiful sister always had in high
school like the the most judgmental
years for a young girl and was using all
that stuff yeah with sea breeze and oxy
ten and second all that and it was
so frustrating for her I remember the
first time I saw a Proactiv commercial
and it was this whole thing of like
gentle cleansing and this and the all
the before and after pictures and I was
just like we've truly come into a new
age where they've prioritized this
problem and actually solved it not just
like here's a bunch of to scrub
your face with it's the wrong thing
right but it actually did research like
that's why I I feel like those people I
hope they make billions of dollars
because then kids don't have to have
horrible acne anymore yeah it's
the worst it's I was lucky my mom and I
never
had bad acne problem uh but my mom gave
divvied out all acne advice oh don't
touch it never pop it yeah you leave a
whitehead okay forehead for ya of course
that my mom did the exact same thing
don't don't pick your skin don't pick
your face where it's like what am I
supposed to do went to a place and paid
someone that's what they do
yes you got to get rid of it I think I
don't remember of a someone
professionally I know that there's
people out there that professionally if
you get a facial they pop zits just like
a civilian
yes you don't do it they may be clean
their fingers they were usually with
they'll wear gloves yeah hopefully and
they do it like in they do it in a
circular motion
they don't scar break your skin wearing
gloves makes you a specialist call me up
doctor and I've been a pro skier I don't
know if that makes sense but I'm just
saying gloves don't make you you know
what I mean well don't worry see gloves
to pop zits that's not going only
because it makes it harder to pinpoint
you're squeezing half your face if
you're doesn't then don't get me started
on mittens I can't even I can't even get
my boot in the bindings now we are now
Scottie it's so gorgeous
I love it this is Instagram ready this
guy I'll take a picture do it it's so
big just it's all clouds it looks like
I'm sure the chemtrails people are going
batshit bananas tonight beautiful we're
gonna have this picture on the as soon
as I looks ugly to have someone's
taillights in front of it get those
birds on the wire in there
my windshield is so I washed my car and
then scrubbed it down with a towel that
I and like I said before previously had
used to clean an elephant's butt hole or
something it's very dirty towel very
dirty towel
I don't know why I ruined my car wash
anyway I got a picture of the beautiful
sky okay we'll be a that will go on the
website that we have built here yes yes
no I'll just put it as an image for this
episode where are the lights on them I
just turned the thing over here thank
you
yeah you just twist it it's probably the
same as your Honda well well this was a
good episode did you have an enjoyable
time I really did I laughed and it's
funny it's kind of fun to be in the car
as just a novelty treat I gotta say I do
love the car it was fun right I mean I
think it's where I think there's
something about the distraction of the
drive and the changing scenery that
makes it like when we're in the studio
as much as I love it cuz it's convenient
yeah it's it's almost it's so static it
feels almost tiring right right
I was exciting at first but now I'm
seeing the benefits of being in car
maybe sometimes we'll do the car
sometimes I think we can I think when we
have time I mean my job is getting to
get easier because we just finished
taping my episode for my show so the
work I mean I'll still obviously there's
six more episodes to make sure I will
just that basically I think just this
this conversation is making some people
just jump up and down about what enjoy
with Joey they like it in the car they
do like it in the car I want to give it
listen if there's people that actually
regularly listen to it then I want to
give them what they want out of the
stupid show don't you I mean
this is if this changes your life
somehow let's make it good for you yeah
for me honestly I'm such a it's almost
like OCD I just want that the title of
the podcast to still match what it is
not a dumb reason what do you mean oh
like that we're doing it being middle
rotted
but then we're in a studio impute new
people but I don't know I know there was
somebody the other day that asked me
about it and then I was like but now we
do it in the studio and then they were
like wait why and then I was just like
I mean it's more I'm we've convinced
ourselves it's more convenient yeah yeah
well bogan yeah well well occasionally
be in its duty I was just nice to have
that option because it sounds so good
well and it's fun it's a fun changer up
mm-hmm
I mean riffing wise yeah yeah do you
have any plugs um what I was gonna wear
April and I were gonna work on a little
Northwest tour of sorts were throwing
together good good i solidified but late
November early December that's great
how do we find he said Seattle this uh
Portland knows those other towns that
exist Pacific Northwest before I heal
it's my favorite part of the country and
honestly it is the best when I was up I
think we talked all about it on this
podcast but when I was up there a year
ago for that old Jane comedy festival
yeah I wanted to live that cuz again
moist moisture so many women wearing
clogs yes so many women with hair like
mine earthy the clog sorry I was still
on the clock no no I say you have earthy
hair that would be kind you know I am
now this guy's turning pink blue and
gold this is quite amazing quite this is
like that dress that split the nation I
think it smells good loo well I think
you're a communist so a girl got really
mad at me because I saw a gold and white
dress in the photo it's a golden white
dress and someone's like I am looking at
a black blue and black a blue and black
dress and you're lying to me right now
and I'm like I think you're lying I
don't believe that you actually see that
yeah it was so hard and how has it not
been explained to me um well I mean you
probably haven't like really tried to
look at like a youtube video somebody
explaining it right
or anything I know I don't have that
kind of time because they do explain it
it's just it's just the way some
people's like eyes pull in light or
something it just threw me off because
how many times then is someone wearing a
crazy outfit like when you do see
someone with pink socks and a orange
shirt and they think it's the same is it
a colorblind thing no it's a lighting
thing I just don't it's light and it's I
think the way some people's eyes are I
don't I think it's just it's that kind
of anomaly because I see blue and black
I cannot understand how people see gold
and why it doesn't make sense to me
and and what I love about it is really
it seems to me to be kind of it's very
representative of like the way this
country has gone politically where
people see things differently and refuse
to entertain that the way other people
see things could be right well yeah with
this I couldn't I was like there's no
way your eyes are seeing how often is
this come up then in life where because
of lighting you're seeing a different
thing than me this dress is the first
instance where everyone was like holy
right exactly well it's and that's
a good thing to doubt your own
perception because we're all just flawed
human beings with that project and have
weird rods and cones in our eyes and who
the knows we're constantly firing
the routes that the rods that is the
cones of course receiving oh is that
true light nah who knows maybe it's like
if your rods are bigger then you see
blue and black and if your cones are
bigger you see yellow and gold yeah I
know I my rods bigger when I see some
nice cones good bye just roll into the
street
Karen no that's not the joke I want you
to die on wait did I ever tell you this
story our friends our friends the
gardener's it was my mom's best friend
Cynthia Gardner her daughter Carrie who
was eight now like a surgeon or
something she's really smart and really
my we always heard stories about Carrie
Gardner she was so funny and when she
got taught how to drive
when she they drove home from her
driver's test she was so excited she was
driving home with her dad and she was so
excited to tell her mom that she passed
her driver's test that as they were
pulling up to the house she saw her mom
in the driveway and she got out of the
car as she was driving toward the house
oh my gosh she took off the seatbelt and
got out I was like mom I passed and got
out of a moving car and then what
happened to the moving car the dad had
to reach over and like pull the
emergency brake I
and that's like my favorite story
because it wasn't she's in no way dumb
or even an airhead
yeah did she just like was excited and I
kind of forgot have you ever noticed
this Toyota dealership how they propped
up mannequins to look like people what
we wanted to look like people are
looking to purchase cars there's many
many customers everywhere around our lot
and you can be one too and sometimes
they are wearing clothing that is very
bleached by the Sun for many years and
sometimes their faces are plastic are
you doing Russian what is this is I it's
I'm not racist enough to pinpoint knacks
and I just spread it across the board oh
goodness I hear no evil I I don't know I
was just a car dealer all right I could
have been like hey do you want a new car
look at all these interested buyers that
would have been better I feel like I
would have been more comfortable and
less triggered if you had done that
cement this has been a very racist
episode of a Chris Fairbanks very what
has happened to me I moved to this city
you start seeing things color only there
were some people who claim to see no
color total and also not the
goal it was a fun of fun the funnest
thing ever for my sister and I to quote
lines from coming to America we really
love that movie when I was young and and
then she in college she took African
American Studies and came home one day
and she said hey we can't I can't do
those voices anymore
did you cos used to scream sexual
chocolate at each other like the way my
friend Jennifer Joe Lewis best boxer
leap you know we had and what and then
it was like that's wrong and I endured I
was like okay I guess you're right I
mean it's not fair though because Eddie
Murphy when I was growing up Eddie
Murphy was Eddie Murphy was right there
in my life in the same way George
Clooney was where it's like right at it
right at the best age you know that was
the guy that was in every movie in on
every TV show and so we were his fan we
listened his stand-up tapes yeah like he
was everything and you wanted to talk
like him because you wanted to do say
funny things like yeah yeah but yeah you
but also you're not allowed to look look
at the sky look at this guy oh my god
we're taking this guy look at this guy
look at this guy
that looks awesome and that's all
pollution oh there's always a car in the
way it's hot pink well go on Instagram
for the evening of August night and
you'll see
I mean October yeah yeah it's gonna be a
trending topic for as far as sunsets
okay and it's a if you see any sunset
picture it's about our podcast dying are
yes yes unless of course you're talking
about Indian weddings and then dine our
babies in China I think the Indian one
is dine our baby right I think so yeah I
think so
so congratulations to them do you need a
reception is what their hashtag oh good
yeah you're okay that's all I want I
gotta say this was your episode Karen
what did I really shine
yeah oh I just I gave a lie a little bit
of a luster here and there but it was
mostly asleep at the wheel
um I disagree but here's what I will say
my my plug is is that we're doing
business class this Wednesday oh yes you
found Los Angeles on Wednesday October
the 12th I believe is Wednesday
laboratory 10:00 p.m. improv lab Chris
Fairbanks Karen Kelly Arif April
Richardson yeah
there's there's some really good people
I think Dave Anthony's doing it oh cool
I think really might be doing it cool
Andrew Michonne I believe is doing it
he's skateboard King he's really good at
skateboarding to talk to him about
skateboarding he's he rips I love him do
it that I love knowing that fact I wish
I knew a fact like that about every
person I knew yeah yeah it's while my
phone doesn't work in the city I live in
so I've been able to look anything up
okay good yeah perfect anyway you are
we've we've concluded this episode of
good one you enjoyed it you've been
listening do you need a ride
Dyn they are Hong Kong we're in traffic
we didn't wanna how can I leave in are
you on your way back
either way we wanna be there
doesn't matter how much baggage you
claim give us time and made terminal and
gate we wanna stand you up inside we
wanna welcome you back home tell us all
about it we scared or was it fine now
do you need a ride do you need a line do
you me ride do you need a ride do you
need
with Karen and Chris